how's it going my name is terminals in
one day
what is days this is old put a PI and
that's exactly why I'm making this video
bet you weren't expecting this video
worried you can't see the future can you
you can you're not my mom Oh anyway I
just wanted to make this video so you
bros can understand what's going on
behind the scenes kind of so for those
of you who don't know a few weeks ago I
moved into a new flat and Internet has
not been working properly it's been
going on and off it's been a nightmare
in case you didn't know I need internet
to upload videos and I do that every
single day so it's been so [ __ ]
annoying it's a long story but anyway
I've been getting a lot of complaints
saying like before before you upload two
years or three videos okay now you only
upload one but it's like I haven't had
any internet and I feel like I could
have just said [ __ ] it I'll just not
upload videos until internet comes back
but I've been working really hard to
actually get the videos out for you bros
and instead I get a lot complaints that
it's not enough so I just wanted to
explain that it's because I haven't had
internet so basically what I've been
doing instead is I I put the videos on
my laptop I go out with my skateboard
and I still Wi-Fi from my neighbor's I'm
sorry neighbors but yeah it's that's how
I've been doing it since I can only make
one video a day I've been trying to put
a lot more effort into that video and I
really really love that I like I feel
like I made some really really good
videos lately like this is everything
and fab Eliezer and I both really love
the skate 3 episodes so I feel happy
that I can put out content that I'm more
proud of
so I actually really really like just
doing one a day I am planning however to
do two a day ones and you playthrough
starts maybe like the 4s or some new
horror game comes out because honestly
just playing through a game takes so
little effort it takes maybe a tenth of
the time that takes for an actual edited
episode don't worry I am planning to do
two in the future and once internet get
back on a completely different note I
just want to say thank you both so much
for 20 million subscribers that's crazy
I mean we were at 10 million not long
ago at all it feels like just a few
months ago it's it's so insane I am I
really mean it when I say I appreciate
every single one of you bros for
supporting this channel oh yeah
whether it's been four years now or just
to subscribe yesterday I really
appreciate every single one of you
because you really do make my dreams
come true I love making these videos
every single day and that's why and
that's why I worked so hard on it
because I love doing it and I love how
long how you bros like it I guess I
don't know I had something better
planned for 20 million but it's gonna
take a little bit more time so
unfortunately all you get is - thank you
right now but something bigger is coming
and just wanted to let you both know as
always stay awesome bros I know you will
I know you have what I knew you see this
you see this do you do you skip the
brofist or you you can't you're not a
bro if you skip the brofist main woman
spider how do you even use the keyboard
anyway 20 million people should be doing
this right now that's I don't believe
that all right here we go sales and risk
love you
you